so now in Coachella this was interesting
because Coachella just passed and um
it's always good at Coachella to see a
40 year old comedians going I have a
ticket is there anywhere I can stay
is there anywhere I can stay can someone
house me I'm going to Coachella I'm 60.
can someone house me I'm elderly
I've left my family to go to Coachella
does anyone have a floor I can plop on
now Coachella is a festival in the
desert where there is music and uh
people are let loose because there's not
enough time in our society to really
just let loose and relax and there's not
enough music festivals in my opinion
that's a big problem and these are young
usually good or decent looking people
that are out there living the California
Dream this is the California Dream it's
being on drugs being uh outside and
being uh in the presence of celebrities
that's the thing that's what the dream
is I'm on drugs I'm outside and someone
famous is that way that's why this state
exists and Coachella is a distillation
of that people going and I'm dressed
like a Native American I'm a white
person dressed in wacky Garb I'm in a
mud pit and I'm uh there's Nicki Minaj
that's what it is and I I haven't been
I'd like to go I want to see it I'm not
above it I'm sure it's very enjoyable uh
but I haven't gone I'm always working
I'm working I can't do it but
um all of these people that went the
people at Coachella supposedly somebody
somebody went and asked them how much
money they make and if their ticket was
worth it and uh
I guess this was uh
so the ticket cost about five hundred
dollars
is there a video of this
oh no this is just a uh like a opinion
piece or you know sort of like a feature
thing just photos of the people with
their Danielle made 37 her pronouns are
I'm sorry now Daniella's 37 years old
her pronouns are she her
income is 210 000. I'm a rich Auntie I'm
a single woman in the world well that
sounds fun
nothing sounds funner than that 210
Grand Rich antium a single woman in the
world we're worth it
here's what she said
I like the diversity of the artists
what
I don't even know
I like that I'm not crowded or
overwhelmed even the food I would say is
worth it like today we're having chicken
fingers but yesterday we had fantastic
dumplings
I mean all these people's brains have
been broken
I like the diversity of the artist even
the food's good chicken fingers
dumplings they got it all
I mean
it's very organized we were talking
about like how East Coast festivals
people are kind of pushy nobody pushed
me once
I have not been pushed I can eat my
chicken fingers in peace without being
pushed and it's only five hundred
dollars
maybe people run into you walking and
stuff like that well that's what they
that's what it is no one's pushing you
what do you mean on East Coast festivals
people are just like hey and then
pushing you
but we were pretty far up for Calvin
Harris I didn't feel any surge of the
crowd everyone is just nice Gabriel
Vieira pronoun shihar
27 this is gonna be the age 27 27 to 37.
lives in New York City makes 80 000
first time at Coachella worth it
honestly we've gone to a few other
festivals and this does feel a lot more
organized and spacious I'm very happy to
be here
well that was detailed Rolando Garcia
pronouns he they
age 26 lives in Austin Texas of course
occupation none
no income unless you count mommy and
daddy first time at Coachella yes
worth it Rolando says yeah
I've had a great time I've been doing
festivals for years and I feel like this
is a festival on easy mode because
everyone is so nice no one's up against
you for any reason what are other music
festivals like I mean how lazy are these
people what are other music like are
other music festivals just mosh pits and
fights where people are berating
everyone's like this one's easy I'm a
career Music Festival goer and uh
Bonnaroo is tough
bonnaroo's hard Austin City Limits
goddamn nightmare
um
he goes worth it yeah I had a great time
I could just walk up to the front for
any reason okay
Alec Mitchell pronounce he him
now by the way not to belabor the
pronoun Point here but like
I don't understand the pronouns of this
article does that mean that they think
people are reading this article and then
they're gonna reference it
foreign
like it's only for me right it's only
for people making fun of it that's
exclusively for podcasters who are
making fun of
he's 25 years old
occupation he's currently studying for
the bar he's going to be a lawyer he
does not have any income none of these
people by the way two of the four have
no income they're at Coachella it's 500
a ticket no income
this is the thing people it's amazing
American society
it's his fourth time at Coachella with
no income he's gone four times
worth it now remember remember no income
as I read this no income it's a super
unique experience and I really like it
because it's one of the only places
where you can unplug
for three days what's he unplugging from
I never check my text or anything
uh Alec I don't know where you are but
your mother's very sick
Alec Alec please answer your mother's
very sick you had mentioned something
about going into the desert I don't know
I don't know if that's I know it's not
work related because you know you don't
work and we don't judge you for that we
know we know the bar is very hard and
you've been studying for it for years
and years and years but I mean there are
a lot of other people that worked their
way through the bar and I'm not bringing
it up but your mother's very very sick
and we don't know what it is the doctor
thinks it's a stroke uh so if you could
please just get back to us
um he goes I never checked my text or
anything it's just so fast paced so it's
really good for decompressing even
though it's a crazy weekend I'm mostly
going with the expectation to just go
with the flow it can be really hectic so
I think getting a good group of friends
and just sort of sticking with them and
accommodating what everyone really wants
to see is the best way to go about it
that's right Alec
Dylan Boda 25 years old she her La
advertising 90 grand a year fifth time
at Coachella fifth
worth it I honestly think this was the
best one yet I don't know if that's just
because I'm older and more experienced
and know how to do it
the setting is amazing because the
desert is just beautiful and obviously
going with a big group of friends you're
making memories that you're just never
going to forget and it's just total
freedom nothing to focus on but music
for three days by the way every
explanation here has been the most basic
explanation of why you would enjoy
anything
no one's hitting me these are adults
it's like why are you enjoying Coachella
they're like I can walk around in the
field and no one says well hey why don't
you have a job
no one says what are you doing with your
life it's the most basic reason to
enjoy anything this is why like children
enjoy things Marco Salazar he him 34
lives in San Diego software developer
makes more than six figures it's his
17th year Coachella God bless give it up
for Marco 17.
worth it yeah because I've been coming
here since I was like 17 or 18. it's
kind of like a formative thing for me I
love coming out to the desert I've lived
nearby my entire life so it's kind of
like revisiting that time when I
discovered music and I'm discovering
more and more new artists every time all
right well that's nice
Ed Benda age 32 lives in Los Angeles
pronouns he him Works in film makes
money more than six figures
I think we're just really excited to
have this experience together he went
with someone named Molly maybe that's a
drug or maybe that's his lady I think
it's his lady yeah we're big gorillas
fans uh personally and that was a ton of
fun and then it was really cool to see
Chromeo we were dancing into the night
this was awesome Molly Benda that's his
check she's like this is the best one so
far it helps when you're with someone
you love we're excited to see Frank
Ocean but also just exploring some new
music well I'm glad everyone's happy I'm
glad everyone was happy
yeah I mean these get worse and worse by
the way 43 marketing
uh having the scheduled area in the VIP
entrance for parking makes to walk
shorter
Georgia 17 she her San Diego student
definitely we met Anderson pack in VIP
okay
Charlize zagabond 23 30 grand personal
assistant second time
I think it was everyone's here for the
same thing have a good time I've only
been twice and I've camped both times
it's fun overall
they've interviewed everyone in
Coachella